so let me start by asking you a question
you're the number five guy what is a
number
a number is an abstract way to represent
a quantity
that's a very good answer i just thought
of that it's a very good answer
i spent i think most of my phd years
thinking
about the answer to that and that's more
or less what i had you should you should
have given me a call
i would have told you
all right you're a hard man to reach all
right
okay good answer
okay are we right what is a number right
so
as you said it's just an abstract thing
that represents quantity now
if you have somebody they might tell you
you know by giving examples so what is a
number well 0 is a number 1 is a number
42 is certainly a number okay
what about half oh okay half is a number
minus 3 over 8 is a number
wait what about the square root of 2 oh
that's also a number
what about pi
you know what about e all of these
things are numbers what about i what
about the square root of -1 right oh
that's imaginary that's not a real
number so i is also a number right it's
just not one that makes sense to you
sort of as a human but in electric
engineering they use i to talk about
electricity flow and stuff like this so
i is also a number you can use other
things as numbers
right
but that still doesn't really answer
mathematically speaking
what's a number
now
i'm gonna give it away i don't have an
answer to that there is no answer to
that
but what can a number be
so
for example a number if you want to have
a
strict foundation of mathematics you
want to say i'm going to start with you
know
one thing and build math on that this is
going to be a bit controversial but the
the de facto standard nowadays is set
theory with the tomato franco axioms or
zfc with the action of choice we're not
going to go into oh that's the the only
one it's not the only one there's a lot
of different ones
but
zfc is one of the main foundations of
modern mathematics first of all what is
a set yeah a set is a collection of
mathematical objects right this could be
numbers or other sets and so on in set
theory everything is a set
so if you think about numbers you're
thinking about sets
now that sounds odd for a lot of people
because you're not used to this but if
you think about computers then a letter
is a number a picture file is also a
number so all these things are
represented using other things it's just
a matter of you know coding stuff into a
system so a lot of times you will see
something that says so let's say that
the number zero is the empty set so this
is the set that has no element nothing
in it think about an empty bag let's say
that we already have defined the number
n so the next one is just going to be
whatever n was defined and we add to it
n itself
so
1 is going to be just zero which is just
the empty set and two is going to be
zero and one right because we had zero
and we add one itself
which is
empty sets
and this
so what would 3 be well 0 1 2 and this
just goes on so in effect a number is
just
0
all the way to n minus 1. so why is one
the empty set i thought zero was the
empty set so this is the set whose
element is the empty set so it's a bag
containing a bag containing nothing
okay right so all numbers are just bags
of nothing it's just how many nothings
have you got kind of
but now we get tricky so this is just
the natural number so 0 1 whatever
what's half what's minus 1 right all of
these things are not represented here
so now you can start you know
let's call it going a bit crazy with
this and you can say okay i'm going to
uh
define
a collection of natural numbers and say
this one represents you know -1 and
another collection that represents -2
and so on and so on and then you can
take those and make you know use this to
represent the fractions
and then you can use
all kind of
constructions to you know go from there
and get the real number so for example
after i defined all the natural numbers
let's call this n how do i get to z
which is the integer so this is also
minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 and so on just
for clarity 0 is a natural number this
is also a very you know contentious
point
so
it is
all right let's just clarify that i'll
put your email address down there
how do we get from here to here well for
example so you want to get from the
natural numbers to the integers so one
way to think about this is to sort of
think about pairs of numbers so i have a
pair let's call them x and y
and
another pair let's call this x prime and
y prime and i want to think that they
represent the same thing
if x plus y prime is x prime plus y so
for example let's put in
0
and 1 this would be x and y and
this would be
three and four let's see if i was right
that's zero plus four equals
three plus one so this is four
so i was right everything works these
two things are kind of the same so let
me you know put this
approximate not exactly equal okay right
and you can use this now to say okay
let's look at all of these pairs of
numbers
that have this kind of thing
and let's call all of these minus 1. so
-1 is now really just all the pairs of
numbers x y
such that
0 1
is the same as
x y and now i can extend the addition
from the natural numbers to this so -2
would be
x y such that 0 2 is the same as x y
under this weak equality that you know
gives you a way to define minus 1 and so
on but you can also redefine 0 so 0 is
now
x y
where 0 0
equals
this x y
which if you think about this just means
that x equals y so that's zero but hang
on zero is the empty set
and now i'm saying it's not the empty
set it's this collection of pairs
and here's the important thing it's just
coding you just have to decide how you
code your numbers right so you say okay
i'm starting from this i'm building the
system up
and then at the end so from this you can
continue and define the rational numbers
the real numbers the complex numbers
whatever and you can say let me end
this at the complex numbers right so i
went from this to
the rational number so
half minus 3 8 whatever and from here to
the real numbers with pi
and the square root of 2 and from here
to the complex numbers with i
and whatever so i can say okay let me
define all of these number systems and
each of those has sort of a canonical
way that the previous one mapped into
that so now i have a canonical way of
putting the natural numbers into the
complex numbers
so the empty set is now you know moved
here to this
particular set and then to that
particular set whatever i end up here
moved to this particular set move to
that particular set now i can decide
that the natural numbers are not this
thing
actually whatever i ended up with as the
copy
in this one
so
what's a number
from a mathematical let's say objective
reality
it's whatever you want it to be
like a really popular question that
everyone always asks on the internet is
do numbers exist or were numbers
invented or are they do they just exist
in the world presumably you think
numbers are very much
a human invention
well
philosophically speaking i'm very
agnostic i don't want to have any
concrete set of beliefs because beliefs
lead you to
being sure that you're right and you
know you can't really know
the point here is that
numbers exist
within a context
and
if you're thinking about set theory as
your context
then numbers are whatever you decide to
mean
whatever you decide that numbers mean in
this context whatever coding you want
you want the standard coding for the
natural numbers
do you want to go into the complex
numbers
you can use different sets you can use
you know the empty set to say i want the
empty set to be five and i want zero to
be some other set
it's fine
right it's all about coding and the the
important thing and this is where you
know
zfc as a set theory has a lot of power
is that it just shows that whatever
coding you did
if it satisfies the basic properties
that you think of for the natural
numbers
it doesn't matter you can always
translate this to that and vice versa so
it's like if you have something written
in ascii and something written in
unicode
you can just move between those two
you know let's say in english without
all the emoji symbols right
so you can just move between those two
encodings and that's fine
could mathematics could
you know modern thought have exist could
exist without numbers like were numbers
necessary or was it just one of the
paths we could have taken to reach where
we are now
so it's a good and interesting question
uh i don't know
but they're so natural but here's
something that people forget sets are
also as natural you know people like to
say oh you know numbers started when you
know like caveman was hunting a mammoth
and was like okay there are two mammoths
and uh two of us so it's the same
quantity but to understand that there
are two mammoths you need to understand
the collection of mammoths and that's
the basic of set theory right so the
basic is not just numbers it's numbers
and sets
or arguably numbers and types so numbers
in some sort of you know collections
and it's just so natural you know i i
don't see how we could have gone without
coming up with numbers
transcendental numbers and so a lot of
the number categories refer to in or out
of these different sets so rational
numbers are everything inside the blue
line irrational numbers are everything
outside the blue line